blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to
blinkist.com pakman welcome to the david
pakman show i am farron cousins from
ring of fire sitting in for david pakman
today and might i also say happy
reinstatement week right
because coming up at the end of this
week august 13th isn't that the day
that the conspiracy theorists tell us
donald trump might be reinstated as
president so you know i guess we have
that to look forward to as well of
course mike lindell my pillow ceo who
david uh had a wonderful interview with
this past week if you haven't seen it
please check it out
uh he had originally said august 13th
could be the day he has since kicked the
can down the road a little bit
maybe it's september he tells us maybe
it's even after that who the heck knows
at this point
but one thing is for certain the
department of homeland security is
certainly taking all of this very
seriously
late last week the department of
homeland security actually sent out
notices
to state and local law enforcement
offices throughout the country that said
this
dhs is providing awareness of reports
regarding an increasing but modest level
of activity online calling for violence
in response to unsubstantiated claims of
fraud related to the 2020 election and
the alleged reinstatement of former
president trump
as public visibility of the narrative
increases we are concerned about more
calls to violence reporting indicates
that the timing of these activities may
occur during august 2021 although we
lack information on specific plots or
planned actions
so homeland security says right now and
they've been saying this for a couple
months in case you haven't been
following that story
listen
we have seen what these individuals are
capable of we saw it on january 6th when
they get worked into a frenzy based on
lies and misinformation we've seen what
they're capable of doing
and over the months since january 6th
they have been pushing this conspiracy
that somehow someway trump's going to
get reinstated so what happens
when that doesn't happen
see that's what they're worried about is
what happens when the conspiracy theory
proves to be totally false
right trump is not
going to be reinstated as president on
august 13th or
at any time unless he wins a future
election and that's not reinstatement
that's winning an election but either
way
people are going to be angry
people who have been led to believe
these things
we don't know how they're going to react
and that is what department of homeland
security is saying they have seen
what they believe to be threats of
violence online however there's been no
specific indication of where when how or
even really if it's going to happen
you know a threat is one thing an actual
plan is a totally different thing and
homeland security is just basically
telling everybody be on the ready
and that's a terrifying thought
right we we don't want to have to live
our lives with this kind of fear of
what's going to happen when the trump
people don't get their way when these
cultists
realize that their conspiracy theories
are totally false we shouldn't have to
live with that
but unfortunately right now this is a
reality
that far too many of us well not far too
many all of us
have to accept
here's another thing too
um and i've talked about this in in
videos on my other channels but you also
have the judges
okay the people hearing the cases
listening to these defendants who were
arrested as part of the january 6th
capitol riot
and the judges have flat out told us
these individuals learn nothing
these individuals are likely to do this
again because the same kind of lies and
misinformation that got these people
worked up in the first place they're
still out there
and these judges
are trained
through years and years of experience
to recognize what a so-called repeat
offender looks like
they look at the psychology
they look at the behavior they look at
mannerisms for god's sake
and they see it as they have told us
with some of these individuals
and we've also had at least one judge
come out and say i'm afraid these people
are getting off too lightly
for what they actually did that day and
therefore will definitely not learn a
lesson and these are people we're going
to have to keep watching because they're
likely to do it again
and that's what homeland security is
trying to tell us
nobody wants to live in a police state
trust me
but they're concerned
that what happens this weekend
when trump doesn't get reinstated
could be very bad for the country
and if you don't believe that these
people are actively organizing
then take a look at this story you have
a trump ally
by the name of matt
brainard
um who says that they're going back to
the capitol he appeared on steve
bannon's podcast last week where he said
quote as we continue to raise the
profiles of these individuals talking
about the people who were arrested in
the capital riot it makes it harder and
harder for the left's phony narrative
about an insurrection to stick
we're going to push back on the phony
narrative that there was an insurrection
and they have
scheduled a justice for j sixth rally
in dc
for september 18th september 18th is the
date that he gave
on steve bannon's podcast
now he says that he has gone through
he's gotten this whole thing approved
according to what he said during this
interview
this is a planned rally that is going to
take place he also says he totally has
lawmakers
signed up that are gonna you know come
and speak at this little event of course
he won't tell us who they are yet
but you know if i had to make a guess as
to the kind of people that would speak
at this
uh perhaps some mo brooks jim jordan
matt gates marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert uh those kind of seem like the
folks that would be drawn to an event
like this of course time will tell he
again has not released their names he
says they will once they're totally
confirmed to the event but folks we now
have a date
we have a date
of when they're going back to washington
dc september 18th
that's the day that they've planned
and this is supposed to be just the big
rally to raise awareness
about the
conditions of the people who were
arrested but here's the other part of
this story folks we have seen both matt
gates and marjorie taylor green and i
believe jim jordan was with him as well
make a spectacle of themselves as they
always do trying to go into the jail
where some of these january 6th
defendants are being held
now they didn't have pre-clearance they
didn't have an appointment they showed
up with a film crew knowing they were
going to be shoved away
because you can't just do that and then
they tried to use that as some kind of
justification that oh obviously the
conditions these people are being held
in are so terrifying they won't let us
in
there is no evidence at
all
to suggest that any of these individuals
are being treated inhumanely or unfairly
while they're waiting in prison okay
no evidence exists
to suggest any of that
so let's get that very clear right now
the people pushing that are the ones who
i guess have a vested interest
in getting people to think
that bad things are happening to these
individuals because i don't know maybe
they get to have more people show up at
their rally
if they think that these people are
being held in inhumane conditions or if
that they're somehow being treated
unfairly but again don't get sucked into
those lies because there is no evidence
to suggest that any of this is actually
happening it is a political talking
point it is a political stunt it is pure
theater
so don't buy into it
but what we do obviously have to be
concerned about is last time we had a
gaggle of these folks show up in
washington dc
it ended in the january 6 capital riot
now you can call it a riot if you want
you can call it an insurrection you can
call it a failed coup call it whatever
you want you know terminology we can
quibble over all day long and it's a
pointless conversation the fact of the
matter is these people showed up there
on january 6th broke into the capital
smashed windows broke down doors
multiple people on both sides the police
officers and the individuals who stormed
the capitol dead from this
we don't need another show like that
we don't need something like this to
happen again so i hope the authorities
are taking this seriously not to go down
there and bust them up if they've got
permits for it hold your rally
it's going to be filled with lies and i
hope nobody walks out there actually
thinking anything you're saying is true
but if you've done the due diligence if
you filed the paperwork you have a right
to assemble and nobody should infringe
upon that
we just got to make sure that dc is
protected and that these individuals
don't once again fall victim to the lies
of charlatans who know what they're
saying is false oh and by the way
always happen to disappear
before things get too rowdy
you know so they can say oh i wasn't
even there for that i was just there for
the rally yeah they throw you folks
under the bus
remember that if you travel to dc for
that september 18th justice for j6 rally
and while we're on the topic of election
lies
let's talk about lynn wood for a moment
the trump-loving lawyer
recently got smacked down in an
embarrassing way
by yet another court over his bogus
election fraud claims
now linwood
i'm sorry he's such a comical character
if he weren't so you know obviously
whatever but anyway
linwood
goes out
december of last year files multiple
different lawsuits alleging fraud but
the main ones he filed were in the state
of georgia where he had two separate
lawsuits going one challenging the
results of georgia's presidential
election the other one actually came a
little later in january challenging the
senate
election and in that challenge which the
first one the election challenge in
general was thrown out uh said it was
baseless the other one got thrown out
for a second time
by the court of appeals late last week
because they said that lynn wood you
have no standing in this case
so here's what lynn wood was actually
challenging here wood came out and said
that because they changed the rules the
state
changed the rules for signature
verification the whole thing is
fraudulent and you cannot trust it they
didn't have the same um
signature verification
for the absentee ballots that were
obviously very prevalent
in that georgia runoff election so the
first court that looked at this way way
way back in early this year
said yeah you don't have standing to say
any of this
the state legislature controlled by
republicans passed a law that gave their
republican secretary of state brad
raffensberger the ability to change the
rules for the absentee ballots because
it was in the middle of a pandemic they
knew they were going to have a lot of
absentee ballots they were counting on
it that is what their election was
basically going to have to be because of
the pandemic he had the authority to do
this the authority given to him by the
state
you therefore have no standing linwood
and the court of appeals last week
basically told him the exact same thing
you have no injury you have no actual
claim of illegal activity again because
he was given the authority to do this
states as we all know have the authority
to determine how their own elections are
run
without the interference of outside
forces
so no mr wood you don't get to come into
these courts and tell us that something
illegal happened when all of the changes
that you're actually challenging were
approved by the state
no injury no illegal activity
no standing
for mr lynn wood
i don't know how many total court losses
this brings us to at this point with
people like lynnwood and giuliani and
sydney powell but i can promise you
they're going to continue to lose
but of course that hasn't stopped the
republicans in all these states where
the lawsuits are losing from enacting
these highly oppressive and repressive
voting laws
so
that i guess is the silver lining for
republicans you may be losing the court
battles
but you've won the war on voter
suppression
for now
we have to take a quick break i'm faring
cousins from ring of fire sitting in for
david pakman we'll be right back
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am faring cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and if
you happen to enjoy me here you can
catch me on the ring of fire youtube
channel youtube.com slash the ring of
fire you can also find me on my youtube
channel youtube.com slash fair and
balanced of course i'm all over all
social media outlets facebook twitter
instagram at
farren
balanced
now let's talk about covet for a minute
right
obviously
biggest story happening in the country
right now especially as we have children
heading back to school within the next
few weeks florida where i am right now
20 percent of nationwide coveted cases
coming from this state our kids go back
to school today
and we still don't have statewide mass
mandates because our governor ron
desantis
actually signed a ban
on mass mandates it was an executive
order to be perfectly honest
and the republican-controlled
legislature by the way a long time ago
during the pandemic actually gave him
the authority to do that
now as i mentioned on this program
on friday some counties have defied
santa's order uh desantis's order and so
over the weekend though
you had republican senator bill cassidy
from the state of louisiana actually
come out on cnn state of the union and
take a couple shots
at ron desantis for banning mask
mandates for children in school here's
what cassidy said i'm a conservative i
think you govern best when you govern
closest to the people being governed
and if a local community is having a
their icu is full and the people at the
local schools see that they've got to
make sure they stay open because
otherwise children miss out on for
another year of school and they put in
policy then the local officials should
be listened to
now
he kind of didn't say that as clearly as
possible but he was asked about the
masked mandates because we have one here
in florida they got one in texas two of
the worst states in the country with
kovid
and that was his response like you gotta
let the local officials make those
decisions
not every county here in the state of
florida is as bad as the one next to it
now it's bad all over the state don't
get me wrong
but this should be this
the decision excuse me
up to the local officials here but
desantis took away
cities and counties right
to make that decision for themselves and
that is what cassidy is actually taking
a swipe at here
we've seen it happen in arkansas we're
seeing it happen in texas
where the actual authority is being
stripped from local communities
and instead given to one person at the
top of that food chain florida it's
desantis arkansas who now says he
regrets it is hutchinson texas it's
abbott
meanwhile louisiana who is also seeing a
massive spike in covet they're going
back to mass mandates
okay it's a red state
but
they have enough good sense to say
listen things are bad
and so we have to go back to this if
people aren't going to voluntarily
protect themselves we're going to have
to put the law in place the rule in
place
that says you have to protect yourself
because it's not just you
it's literally everybody else around you
and that's when it changes from being
about personal choice as too many
republicans want to say
to a public policy health issue
and that is
something that can be governed that is
something that can be legislated
if it is a public health concern what
you and your individual choices are
then yeah
that can be regulated
people love to use the example of drunk
driving
and that really is a great example if
you want to sit on your couch
and drink a handful of vodka and then
just pass out for the night
that's your personal choice
okay and as long as you're of age nobody
can stop you from doing that
however
if you want to drink that same amount of
alcohol then get behind the wheel of a
vehicle then yeah suddenly that's a
public health concern
and we do have laws against that because
at that point you put other people in
danger it's the same with not wearing
masks maybe not to such an extreme
extent
but we do have a virus that is still
mutating that is still spreading that is
highly transmission transmissible
the delta variant is much more likely to
make children sick than you know covet
original
and this is what we're dealing with
right now
so while i may not agree with him on
quite possibly anything else i do
applaud
senator cassidy for taking the time and
responding to the question correctly
he could have been a little more overt
about it but i'm not going to damn for
that
this should be a decision that's up to
each individual school board after
hearing from parents after listening to
medical professionals
because we've seen far too many videos
by the way of angry deranged anti-vaxxer
parents saying we don't need vaccines we
don't need masks you can probably ignore
those people maybe have the school board
just meet with doctors
or maybe
have them go visit the hospitals in
states like florida and texas that are
currently filling up and then
they should be the ones to make the
decision
on whether mask mandates go into place
and another
another good point about that
according to a new poll a majority of
americans including a large percentage
of non-vaccinated americans actually are
okay
with vaccine
mandates
this is remarkable here it is
according to a late july morning consult
poll 56 percent of adults said employers
should probably or definitely require
covet 19 vaccinations for their
employees and customers only 32 percent
said they probably or definitely should
not that confidence extends to schools
too last month gallup found that 60
percent of americans supported mandatory
vaccines for high school students and 56
percent supported them for middle school
students although among k-12 parents
those numbers were notably lower 47 and
43
respectively
and 28 percent of unvaccinated people
actually support mandatory
vaccines
so all this fear-mongering that we see
coming from the right mostly there is
still some coming from some folks who
claim to be on the left
but
it's all
for lack of a better term
nonsense
it's bs we don't want mass mandates
actually look at the polls people do
they're okay with it
they don't see it as a violation of
their freedom
they see it as protecting other people
hell when you have 28 percent of people
who aren't even vaccinated yet saying
yes this thing should be mandatory
that tells you a lot here
and unfortunately
that is probably where we're headed
i say unfortunately because there are
still people who are hugely against this
and i wish we honestly didn't have to
get to the point where we had to mandate
this thing
but
too many people fell for the
misinformation
too many people fell for the lies
and so now here we are it would have
been great
if we had every eligible and healthy
enough person because that's an
important distinction to make
who was able to get the vaccine if they
had gotten the vaccine and we wouldn't
even be talking about a delta variant
today maybe
and about that distinction real quick
because i do want to point out yes there
are plenty of people here in the united
states who are physically incapable
of getting that vaccine you know
immunocompromised people
people allergic to some of the things in
the vaccine so they can't get it and
trust me whenever i talk about things
like this
i'm not saying you guys should have to
get it at all you cannot it puts you in
danger when you get the vaccine so even
if we ended up with any kind of vaccine
mandates i think they would definitely
have to carve out that exception
for those individuals
but if it's just somebody who says no i
don't want to get it because i saw a
video and a woman said it made her
magnetic
okay you know what that's not a valid
reason because that's not actually a
thing that happened
i'm sure we've all seen that video
from from ohio where they were having
the hearing and the woman came in and
said look even my keys stick to me and
then the key didn't
didn't stick to her
because she's not magnetic
and i think david actually pointed out
on social media um has anybody even
thought about maybe being magnetic isn't
that bad you know what what really is
the drawback to that it was humorous of
course
but
here's the thing and this isn't so funny
we're at a point
where most people in this country
who are of eligible age
there's no longer the long lines
there's no longer the fight to get in to
get the vaccine
they're open
you can go to most pharmacies here in
the united states
if there is a line you're going to wait
a couple of minutes
and you can go and get this vaccine
it's it really is that simple for those
who are eligible and are not in any kind
of danger when receiving the vaccine
that's where we're at
and most americans understand that and i
think that's why these poll numbers are
the way that they are
because people see you know what we
could be getting this yes covet is
getting worse and i see that now
not to mention of course all of the
stories that we've seen
of uh people who didn't get vaccinated
then died
and unfortunately we have another one of
those
uh last week a former newsmax host and
right wing shock jock as they're calling
him by the name of dick farrell
died
of covet
now farrell had spent a lot of time
during the pandemic
trashing dr falchi
calling the entire pandemic a scam
dimmick
and essentially trying to downplay
everything downplay the effectiveness of
the vaccines casting doubt on those
casting doubt on the pandemic itself
saying oh this is democrats trying to
control things
dies last week from kovid
but before he died
he had one of those come to jesus
moments that we have seen far too often
in the people who die from the back
excuse me die from the virus
he texted his friends
telling them go get the vaccine
so here was somebody who had devoted
more than a year
of his media career
to try
to convince people that this wasn't real
that this wasn't a big deal that it was
all a scam
and the last thing he did on this earth
was tell his closest friends
it's real
protect yourselves
get the vaccine
now he's dead
we also had this story last week of
scott apley
from texas republican official
on a county board from texas
he died of covid
he died a coveted five days
after posting anti-vaxx material on
facebook
left behind a young i believe infant son
left behind a wife
dead from covid
these stories
of people dying from covet after
spending a year and a half
pretending it didn't exist are becoming
far too common we are now at the point
where we're getting at least one per day
and a lot of them all in the same way
before the person dies they're tweeting
out they're texting out they're doing
whatever they can they're calling their
loved ones and saying please get the
vaccine
i can't believe i didn't do this i was
too stupid
some of them have said
and that really is what we're looking at
here folks
i'm willing to bet i would never have
agreed with anything dick farrell ever
said
ever
in his political career
and i still wish that that man were
alive today
same thing with mr scott aptly same
thing with all of these people
that are dying because they didn't want
to do the one thing that probably would
have saved their lives
every death is a tragedy
it doesn't matter if it's on the right
or on the left if it's a anti-vaxxer or
if it's a you know whoever
every death is a tragedy
and and it's unnecessary at this point
too
stories like this are hard stories like
this are getting very very hard to
report on but i do want to continue to
do this because hopefully they get
through to some people
hopefully this acts as the wake up call
when you hear these stories
of people gasping in their final breath
saying i wish i'd gotten the vaccine
asking their doctors
can i still get it
and the doctor having to tearfully tell
them i'm sorry
but it's too late
that's the country we're living in now
and that's a country
that has been consumed with
misinformation
i'm farron cousins and for david pakman
we'll be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and
don't forget you can find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire and
youtube dot com slash fahren balanced
we had a lot of movement over this past
weekend on the infrastructure bill the
slim down
infrastructure bill we still of course
have reconciliation on the other part
which
unfortunately not going so well but
let's talk about what is kind of
going well at this point
senate did vote to move forward
on infrastructure negotiations
infrastructure debate
really good like i said positive
developments it looks like you are
getting some republicans who are
starting to come around to this
obviously whatever happens in the senate
this thing still has to go through the
house of representatives where it's
going to go through even more changes so
far from over at this point
but
we are seeing
forward progress
but there's somebody who's not happy
about forward progress somebody
who has been shouting for two weeks now
that forward progress is a bad thing and
you guessed it ladies and gentlemen that
person is none other
than former president donald j
trump
trump issued a warning
to republicans over the weekend he said
joe biden's infrastructure bill is a
disgrace
will be very hard for me to endorse
anyone foolish enough to vote in favor
of this deal
you know what i love about that
statement
it's such a small statement okay it's so
tiny it's just a little sentence
two sentences i guess technically
but uh it says so much
about american politics today not just
about trump not just about the
republican party but it says so much
about politics
so i have to break this statement down
again this tiny little statement i'm
breaking it down
three different ways the first one
is take off partisan blinders
get rid of hatred for trump
get rid of support for infrastructure
all of that let's just look at this as
political strategy because what i'm
going to say here might shock you
from a strategy standpoint
trump is right
i know i know
it's weird to even say it
but
he's right
what's the republicans best chance to
win
in the 2022 midterms
showing the public that the democrats
couldn't get anything done showing the
public that all these lofty goals of the
democratic party fell flat
and of course by doing that they're
going to omit the part where they're the
ones who made it all fail that's how the
talking point works
but
mitch mcconnell was very clear a couple
months ago when he said on camera we've
got to make sure that they can't move
forward on their agenda because
mcconnell knows the same thing
they've got to make a pitch to voters
because so far all their attacks on
biden have failed that's another
important thing to remember folks
all their attacks have failed so far
because they don't have anything real to
attack him on
so
if they give him this infrastructure
package that is a big win for the
democratic party
not as big as it should have been
certainly not as big as they were asking
for in the plan but if the democrats
produce if the democrats go to the
public and say we got you this
because remember it's not just an
infrastructure plan folks it is a jobs
plan
that is widely supported by members of
both parties out there in america
so again this is only looking at this
through nonpartisan eyes
trump saying do not support this
that is
what the republicans would be doing
except of course the other side of that
strategy
and this is where trump is totally wrong
on it
as i just mentioned majority of
republicans out there support this
heck a majority of republicans even
support raising taxes on the wealthy and
corporations to pay for it
they supported it before it was even cut
down to 1.2 trillion they liked it when
it was three and a half trillion
they want the plan
so they would be less likely in turn
based on that to believe republican
talking points that democrats were
unable to deliver because they're
clearly paying at least somewhat
attention to this issue
and that's another positive development
they know who's holding this thing up
they know that they want it and they
know that republicans and to a degree
mansion and cinema don't want them to
have it
so that's why republicans are stuck
between the rock and a hard place here
on terms of strategy
they want to get democrats to lose
but they can't have their voters who
support this bill know that they were
the ones who kept it from making it to
them
so i think at this point some of them
clearly not all of them but i do think
some of them
have looked at this and said you know
what
the best path forward for us
is probably to let this thing happen
at least hey maybe then
if there are some positive developments
out of it once it passes i can go back
to my constituents and tell them i
supported this thing i did this for you
i did this for you
so that could likely be the strategy
that these people take moving
forward and of course
there's also the third part
and that is
who cares if trump withholds his
endorsement
there was a study that came out last
week and i actually uh spoke about this
on my other channels because it's a
phenomenal study i love it they looked
at races where donald trump endorsed a
candidate versus races where donald
trump did not endorse a candidate
and the political scientists who looked
at all of these endorsements and all of
the outcomes
came to a statistical conclusion
that a donald trump endorsement
makes you two and a half percent less
likely
to win your race
candidates who received the trump
endorsement again two and a half percent
not two and a half times two and a half
percent
less likely to win so it's a very very
tiny tiny
disadvantage
but it's a disadvantage nonetheless
and
the report also did mention that yeah
when trump endorses a candidate they end
up raising a ton more money but you know
who else does
their opponent
every time trump comes out and endorses
somebody they raise more money but so
does their opponent
they also found that voter turnout
actually does increase in races where
donald trump endorses a candidate but
again in most instances
it benefits the opponent
not
the person trump endorsed so trump wants
to be the king maker he's out there
pretending to be the king maker he's
threatening them trying to scare them
into submission saying i'm not going to
endorse you if you don't do this and
republicans need to respond with respond
with uh good
like please don't endorse me in fact
could you endorse my primary opponent
because i really want to win this
election
and your endorsement at this point is
effectively a kiss of death
you're not helping candidates you're
hurting them you're literally making
things more difficult for them
so don't come out there acting like well
i'm gonna withhold my endorsement
don't threaten us with a good time man
we've seen the numbers we know what the
data looks like we know that your
endorsement doesn't change people's
minds
and when it does
it changes them in favor of the other
candidate
so again republicans you're not actually
stuck between the rock and the hard
place here
you've got a pretty easy out
vote in favor of the infrastructure
package go back to your constituents
tell them that you delivered it for them
and give donald donald trump the finger
on the way out the door
because trust me you don't want his
endorsement
unless of course you're looking forward
to early retirement
that would really be the only thing
that would work in your favor at that
point
and speaking of people who have things
working in their favor it was recently
reported that u.s postmaster general
louis de joy
has awarded
a massive contract the post office has
awarded a massive contract he swears he
wasn't involved in the process
but they have awarded a massive contract
to a company called xpo logistics
and those who have you who have been
following excuse me louis dejoy's story
for the past year i'm sure that company
name certainly rings a bell right
because xbo logistics happens to be the
company that louis de joy up until
october
held a massive financial interest in
but he divested from that company in
october
kind of citizens for responsibility and
ethics in washington says that this is
really a sham divestment
because all he did was give all of his
holdings to his children
who in turn will most likely just give
it all back to him
once he is no longer the post master
general of the united states and again
the contracts being steered towards expo
that de joyce swears he didn't have a
hand in
total 120
million dollars which could result in a
net windfall for the dejoy family of 23
million
dollars
so the big question everybody has of
course is why is louis de joy still the
postmaster general of the united states
and the answer is because man the post
office infrastructure is set up weird
that is honestly the best way i can
describe it
going through
and i'm not sure if david has explained
this but i'm gonna go ahead and explain
it in a really slimmed down version here
but to just sum it up um incredibly hard
to remove a post master general here's
what's happening biden cannot fire louis
de joy
he is powerless to stop dejoy but what
he can do
is he can appoint new members to the
board of governors of which he's already
nominated three they have not been
approved and then the board of governors
are the ones who get to vote to oust the
postmaster general
here's a problem though there's three
vacancies biden's nominated people for
those and if and when they get approved
democrats will
have the majority on that board of
governors so you would think at that
point that dejoy's history right
nope
because two of the democrats
on that board of governors
were appointed by trump
and those same two democrats actually
voted in favor
of this new deal
so if they're okay with it they they're
okay with the joy
so
biden can get his people there
democrats will have the majority but
they still
probably not going to remove him at that
point so then what's the remedy well i'm
glad you asked the remedy is biden can
fire members of the governor's board
with cause
now that little statement with cause or
four calls i think is how it's phrased
very difficult
because cause can mean anything
and cause can mean nothing
and cause can be a very specific
incident depending on which court is
looking at it and that's what's so
worrisome here
firing these individuals for not
removing louis de joy for a very obvious
conflict of interest would be considered
cause
depending on which court hears this case
now
does it have to go before a court
absolutely not
but if these individuals sue alleging
that there is no cause it would go in
front of a court and the experts have
pretty much agreed that's what would
happen if by if biden fired any of these
individuals
so we are
effectively
stuck for the moment
i know we'd like to think that biden
could do something about this but
honestly
this is one of those times where his
hands are tied
and it sucks so bad
that that is the position that we are in
but unfortunately it is the position
that we are in and the joy it appears is
going to continue to use this position
to make as much money as possible for
when that day comes
when he's no longer the postmaster
general and
to me
that day can't come soon enough
but i'm worried
that it may not come any time soon
i am faring cousins in for david pakman
and don't forget
you can get even more from me on my
youtube channels youtube.com the ring of
fire youtube dot com slash fair and
balanced and i'm on twitter facebook and
instagram at fair and balanced we'll be
right back with more of the david pakman
show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow welcome back to the
david pakman show i am fair and cousins
from ring of fire sitting in for david
pakman today
well i've already talked earlier in the
show about republican strategy for the
midterms talking about the fact that one
of the things they need to do
is make sure that democrats aren't able
to deliver for the american public
but there's another thing that they're
trying to do
republicans across the country
are trying to create these fake
boogey men
to basically drum up their base
and get them to be angry
about something that doesn't even exist
recently writing for business insider
manny fidel
put out a phenomenal article
that i want to spend some time talking
about because it's just so great title
of it here is republicans are winning
political battles by arguing against
non-existent boogeymen
and one of the first examples he talks
about is a tweet
a recent tweet from ben shapiro
where shapiro was whining about you know
the updated cdc guidelines recently the
vaccinated people need to wear masks and
sapira shapiro
started going on a rant
about
hell no he's not going to wear a mask
inside his own house and his wife's not
going to wear a mask inside their own
house and their kids aren't going to do
that and republicans got all drummed up
and said oh hell no that's not happening
and then
none of them bothered to think for a
second that
that's not happening
that's not an actual thing
that the cdc said was was gonna happen
didn't even come close to implying that
nobody has ever said when you're in your
own home you have to wear a mask
but that didn't stop shapiro from
implying that and then of course getting
all of his little lemmings to go along
with it and to become outraged by it
and that is just a tiny tiny sliver
of what republicans are doing they're
trying to strawman their way to a
victory
in the midterms
and as fidel points out
it's because they can't run on actual
issues
now this is something i have been
talking about for years and this is the
point i love to make the republican
party has not had a new idea
in 40 years
the last new idea they had this
groundbreaking new thing they came out
with and said hey look here's a thing
we've created was trickle down economics
and i'm sure we all know how well that
worked out for everybody but again to
their credit it was a new idea
just because it was a horrible idea and
economically devastating idea it doesn't
mean it wasn't new
but that was the last time that that
party collectively put their heads
together and said what can we do
and ever since then it's been a rehash
of the same dang thing every time they
get in power trickle down trickle down
trickle down hasn't been a republican
president in my lifetime
that hasn't overseen some kind of
recession at least one recession
and a lot of it is tied to the
trickle-down economics
and then of course democratic presidents
have to come and try to clean up the
mess we've never rebuilt the economy
from when reagan came out and destroyed
unions and enacted trickle-down for
eight years yeah it's been horrendous
ever since then the middle class has all
but disappeared here in the united
states
and even when we do have the recoveries
like what we're in now we're not
creating good paying jobs but look at me
here folks i am getting off on a tangent
that's a story for another day and maybe
we'll talk about it i've got some more
fill-ins coming next week but anyway
here's the thing
back to the straw man issue
shapiro is not the only one doing it
we have republican governors all across
the country
passing these massive
voter suppression laws and they're doing
it they say
to get rid of all the fraud in these
elections
oh democrats want everybody to have a
right to vote they tell us even illegal
immigrants
we've all heard that talking point not
just from the 2020 election we've been
hearing that talking point from
republicans for well over a decade or
two
democrats want to give illegal
immigrants the right to vote nope
nobody ever suggested that ever
ever
but they use it and the little
republican lemmings go out and they
repeat those talking points you see it
on facebook you see it on twitter
you see it constantly
because there's no critical thinking
they get told a thing that is a blatant
lie
and then they go out and repeat it so
others get outraged by it another great
example
of legislating where it's not
even necessary
transgender athlete bans
right state of florida signed one of
those
oh no if you were born a male you cannot
compete
even if you identify as a female now you
cannot compete in women's sports
that that wasn't a problem we were
having here in the state of florida
in fact even if it were a thing that
were happening it still wouldn't even be
an actual problem
but our governor
in between not letting us protect our
kids from kovid
has been working on all of these
horribly
horribly oppressive laws to address
problems that don't actually exist here
in the united states there is no
epidemic
of
people who were born men
and later identify as women
encroaching on women's sports and just
dominating everybody that that's not
happening
enough to even warrant legislation
especially because this legislation is
clearly
biased because it also says but if
you're a woman if you're born a woman
and then you identify as a man later in
life you can still play you can play
men's sports we're totally cool with
that
so yeah
weird
doesn't address a real actual problem
but the talking points that led up to
that did get republicans in a frenzy
they got everybody thinking oh my god
we've got this horrific thing all the
the men are in women's sports women are
in men's sports who knows what's what
i'm scared and confused and that's why
we end up with this legislation because
they can't actually talk about the real
issues
we've seen it with the tea party
as manny fidel also points out in his
piece
tea party was basically funded by
billionaires from the start
convincing people that obamacare was
going to be communism
or that you were going to be taxed to
hell and back in order to pay for this
two things by the way that never
actually happened
but
they got people to think these things
were true
and they went out there and did the
billionaires bidding
it's the same thing
when you see somebody like marjorie
taylor greene refer to democrats as
communists
they're not communists
but you say it enough
the lemmings believe it the lemmings get
mad about that the lemmings start to
yell we're not going to have communists
in our dang country no siree bob
and they do all of this in fact the
entire culture war exists
because republicans are so terrible on
real issues
they can't talk about the economy as i
mentioned every republican president in
my lifetime has overseen at least one
recession during their tenure they suck
at the
economy well they can't really talk
about middle class because their
trickle-down economics have destroyed
the middle class
they can't really gripe about wages and
what to do about that because they're
the ones kind of holding up the whole
increasing the minimum wage thing
they can't talk about health care
because well they don't want anything to
change and the current system is killing
people
they don't want to do anything that's
actually going to benefit real american
citizens they only care about their
wealthy donors
you know repealing environmental
standards
increasing the amount of mercury in the
air and water that doesn't benefit us
that actually hurts us folks
but they still push this as some kind of
freedom from tyranny
a tyranny that doesn't exist
most of these republican boogeymen don't
actually
exist
but they would rather fight against
these phony enemies because it's really
hard by the way to disprove a negative
so when republicans go out there and
they just make stuff up to be mad about
like oh my god joe biden wants to muzzle
all your dogs out there how dare he
we can go out there and we can say wait
no no he doesn't but they're going to
say but yes he does
show me the evidence where he doesn't
there's no evidence that he doesn't
because he didn't do the thing
so you see what i mean like it is very
hard to disprove a negative
and that's how republicans went on these
issues unfortunately
they get people worked up with lies and
misinformation and and stupid talk to be
frank with you
and then we always end up having to be
on the defensive trying to correct the
record
and unfortunately
that's an uphill battle because by the
time we've
finally figured out a way to address the
nonsense
republicans have already told 10 more
lies
before we could even finish debunking
the first one
and speaking of lies you can't really
talk about lies these days without
talking about arizona right
that ballot audit that actually over the
weekend reports came out said hey it's
drawing to a close
so
you know that'll be fun
i wonder if that'll be you know coincide
maybe with mike lindell's
grand cyber symposium this week
but either way
an even bigger story
came out this past weekend about the
arizona audit and this one is truly
disgusting
and it also is representative of what
we've seen happen to officials all over
the country since the 2020 election
a
republican member of maricopa county's
board of supervisors a man by the name
of bill gates no not that bill gates but
i'm sure that doesn't help with
republicans
he spoke with cnn over the weekend and
he said this
unfortunately
the threats continue and they're not
simply organic
they're being driven unfortunately by
members of the arizona state senate and
other republicans across the country
we receive phone calls into our offices
at the board of supervisors our staff
you know saying that our families are
going to be
slaughtered and threatening us to stop
standing up for the good elections
workers
of maricopa county
so any republican
that dares
to question the narrative of a stolen
election in arizona
any of them who dare
defend the integrity of that election in
arizona
are getting death threats
we have actually seen this happening
in arizona
since
i guess really since the audit started
and there was actually videos of the
angry mob of trumpsters you know that
came in there and wanted to get through
and they weren't allowed to be in there
because it was a ballot audit but we've
seen those videos georgia election
officials
mentioned earlier this year
they were getting death threats even
raffensberger and his wife you know the
republican secretary of state and his
wife said they were getting death
threats
it's happened in pennsylvania the death
threats are coming from these crazed
trump cultists
who genuinely believe that this election
was stolen so anybody who comes out and
says the opposite must be the enemy
there must be somebody to be destroyed
and that is what they're threatening
here folks that that's that's where
we've landed that's where we've gotten
and it's sickening and it's disgusting
and unfortunately the lies that are
causing people to get this worked up are
not ending if anything they're getting
worse
and there has to come a day of reckoning
all of the abuse that these individuals
are suffering all of the death threats
that they are getting
something eventually has to happen to
the individuals getting people this
worked up to to trump himself to to mike
lindell to sydney powell and lynn wood
there has to be accountability for rudy
giuliani
for anyone else out there spreading
these lies
accountability has to happen because
people's lives are at stake now and
they're at stake because of the lies
being pushed
by these deranged individuals who refuse
to accept the obvious and that is
the public rejected donald trump
thank you for sitting here with me today
it's been an honor filling in for david
pakman these uh past two days i will be
back for two more days next week in the
meantime you can find me on youtube
youtube.com fairbalance youtube.com
slash the ring of fire twitter facebook
instagram at fair and balance stay tuned
for the bonus show got some great stuff
coming up there for the members
have a great day
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman